- I heard that you,
is it mixed martial arts you
were really into as well?
- [Sydney] Yeah, MMA! I was fighting.
- You are a very physical person.
Yeah, I like this, it's awesome.
- My mom and my dad would tell me
to try and fall in love with
as many things as possible.
- [Kelly] That's so good!
- So, I would.
- Yeah, how into like MMA did you get?
- [Sydney] Like very into it.
I trained with Ronda Rousey's senseies
I did competitions.
I got first place fighting all guys.
- [Kelly] What?
- [Sydney] Yeah.
- [Kelly] You're a bad-ass.
- [Sydney] Thank you!
- You're like this little petite killer.
Yeah, wait. Did you,
you get hurt doing that?
- Yes.
- Do they frown upon that
with you being an actor
and needing your face to not be bruised?
- Unfortunately, you sign
a little piece of paper
that says you're not to do X, Y, and Z.
And I am all of X, Y, and Z.
- Yeah. I have to do that too.
If you're on a show, yeah.
(stammering)
Luckily, yeah that's why I don't do MMA
it's cause I decided.
- [Sydney] Yeah.
- Yeah, I was like,
fine, I'll put it on the
back burner for ya'll.
It sounds like your parents
were awesome, though.
That's really good advice
to like really get you
involved in everything.
I try and do that with my kids
just because I, I was
involved a lot as a kid
and I felt like one, it
keeps you out of trouble
and two, you start to figure out things
you really like or really get into.
- [Sydney] Yeah. And you
learn more about yourself.
I mean, I grew up in a smaller town,
so sometimes you can get lost
and it's good to stay
focused on something.
- Absolutely. I love a small town.
So your, your new movie is called.
I want to say this so right.
But it's The Voyeurs?
- The Voyeurs.
- The Voyeurs!
See, I feel like if I say the voyeurs,
it sounds like I'm Texan
and people are gonna make
fun of me and be like,
oh, she said voyeurs.
- (in a strange accent) The Voyeurs.
- [Kelly] Yeah. So I was
trying to say, voy-yale.
- [Sydney] It does, I mean
we did film in Montreal,
which is like French Canadian.
- I lived Montreal, by the way.
- [Sydney] It's beautiful.
- Yeah.
- [Sydney] I had such a cultural shock
when I got there, cause I was
like, oh, I'm going to Canada.
I'm going to bring all my jean jackets.
And then all of a sudden like,
oh my God, I'm in France?
What am I doing?
- [Kelly] Go to British Columbia, too.
That's amazing. Vancouver all over there.
But so what, what is it
about what's the movie about?
- So, well, I can't give all of it away.
So me and
- [Kelly] You kinda seem like perverts
watching people in another place.
- [Sydney] We are.
Unfortunately, I become really obsessed
with this couple across the way.
And I start stalking them.
- [Kelly] Oh my gosh.
- And it just turns out really bad.
- [Kelly] Oh my gosh. I
love, is it a kind of fun
to play a crazy person?
- [Sydney] I feel like we're all crazy.
- Well, that's true. Solid point. Touche.